Mình chỉnh thằng xin năm 2018, tại khu vực công chưu phổ thông dân tộc bản chú chung hoặc cơ dự nấm mười,
sát xưa lưu, lào kai, xe ra vụ tên hả thương tâm khiến 2 em dự tử vòng.
Thông tin bàn đầu khoảng 18,5,5,5 em dựa là Chó Bê Pê lợ,
xin năm 2018 và Bê Pê Tê, xin năm 2018, chú tộc tộc tộc nấm mười,
đến chơi ở khu vực công chưu phổ thông dân tộc bản chú chung hoặc cơ dự nấm mười.
Tại đây, chó nước chơi đuồ, chào lên đu vào công rất thì một chú cộng bất ngờ đồ sập.
Đây chúng cả hai khi một chau tử vòng tại chó, chó còn lại dự đựa đi cấp dưới như không quà khỏi.
Ngay sau khi sự việc xe ra, cấp ý, chứng quên xa xưa lưu, bý bán mặt chận tộc quốc bình năng tình lọc kai đá tối thông hả?
Độ viên chia bồn cùng ra đình và chào năm 2018.
Hịt, miên nhân sự việc đăng được cơ quan chức năng tích tục làm só?